hey guys real quick before we start the
video I just wanted to let you know I'm
actually hosting a huge giveaway right
now prizes include an amiibo video game
and even a Nintendo switch console if
you're interested in this competition
which is totally free by the way stay
tuned until the end for more info so the
other day I was at work right me and a
couple buddies all equally nerdy started
talking about who's stronger than who
Mario I mean of course if you're smart
like me the answer is pretty obvious
I mean link has been known to do things
like this but of course some of my
friends weren't convinced by this meager
show of enhanced physical strength so
yeah things may have gotten a little out
of hand and this may or may not be an
actual image of our official debate I
don't look at that for too long you
might catch our stupid but anyway all
that talk made me think of other strong
characters in the games in the recent
Zelda game breath of the wild link has
to battle all sorts of tough enemies I
mean there's literal living rocks giant
cyclopses and even super swole centaur
horse mane things and in mario games our
favorite plumber has his own fair share
of swallow boyos to stomp on the biggest
and baddest of which would be none other
than the King Koopa himself Bowser so
then it hit me another way to determine
which hero is better is by the enemies
they each face and how those enemies
fare against each other link has to face
the livid Lionel's and Mario has to save
the princess from the terrifying Turtles
so the next question is which
fire-breathing baddie is badder as in
stronger also yes I would have gone with
Ganondorf versus Bowser but that's kind
of already been done also also Lionel's
our kind of fan favorites so you know
fan favorites for the win by the way as
I so quickly mentioned earlier I do work
full time but would love to give online
content more of my time as well and one
of the best ways to do that would be to
grow the channel so if you like what
you're seeing and want to check out the
rest of all my amazing and wonderful
content mostly zelda related stuff save
youtube the trouble of guessing and
press that subscribe button with the
bell so you get notified when I upload
more nuggets of greatness or junk or
both I guess we'll see I want to cover a
couple ground rules first before we
start comparing feats of strength
straight up a matte pattern
game theory style first and foremost
this is an arm-wrestle not a death
battle why is this you ask well for one
arm wrestling is freaking cool
- there's no power-ups or environmental
enhancements going on it's just two
contestants one table and muscle a
simple and effective competition based
on pure strength alone well strengthen
maybe one or two other factors secondly
actually that's all the rules so
starting with the Lionel here we go
Lionel's are fallible this is a fact any
Zelda player from the last Oh three
years probably knows that firsthand
but aside from their potent weaponry and
those Swift horse legs just how strong
are they really we're never given a
specific feat of raw strength in-game
really all we see from the Lionel's is
how badly they hurt link when he's you
know showed or torched or lunged upon
but when it comes to seeing exactly what
they can do with those pump-action guns
sadly we're shown very little but that
little bit might just be enough to get a
good estimate going you see every Lionel
is equipped with an Arsenal weaponry
that ranges from the Lionel bow to the
Lionel sword and spear to the downright
terrifying Lionel crusher and on top of
this each weapon has its own mighty and
savage upgrades that make them even more
fearsome both in appearance and damage a
lot of damage one thing that you may
have noticed about these weapons is that
they're rather large I mean especially
the Lionel crusher and these guys swing
that stuff around like it's all made of
styrofoam
of course we smart people know these
weapons are definitely made of a highly
durable metallic substance but something
that massive must be like massively
heavy right so in true matpat fashion
let's try to figure out just how heavy
say a savage Lionel crusher is so that
we can try to determine the strength
required to swing one around like that
and therefore try to put a numeric value
on just how strong a Lionel really is
okay so first things first what metal is
the savage Lionel weaponry made of as we
can see in game in the description of
the savage lentil crusher it mentions
that it is immensely heavy due to being
forged from a rare metal found in Death
Mountain speak now we don't actually get
to see much in the way of precious
metals in breath of the wild when we do
mine
things it's normally rock salt or
precious gemstones that we find so
chances are this mysterious metal that's
found at the peak of Death Mountain
isn't one that we can just go take a
look at in-game so unfortunately we'll
have to go with a couple estimations and
guesses based off what we know about the
weapons the most probable metal for
these weapons to be made of is well
bronze bronze is a metal alloy that's
comprised primarily of copper which has
been known to be mined near volcanoes
historically speaking there was a time
when bronze was the main component used
for weapons and armor by ancient Greece
so it makes sense that a large Lionel
beat stick might be made of bronze it
also fits the other criteria of the
coloration which I even called bronze in
the first place so the next question in
our completely valid logical reasoning
would be how heavy is this large bronze
killing utensil well how big is it if
link is roughly 1.7 meters tall which is
a number I got from this recent game
theory video that would mean the crusher
is really really large especially when
you take its original size into
consideration because it's a known fact
that when link picks up a weapon it
magically shrinks in size to accommodate
for links rather short build when a
Lionel holds a savage crusher that thing
has got to be easily twice links height
in length so to not complicate things
too much let's just estimate that the
crusher is a cone that is approximately
3.4 meters long or twice its height with
a 1.5 meter diameter or just shy of one
full length using the volume of a cone
formula the mass of this massive weapon
comes out to just a hair more than two
cubic meters now that might not seem
like much but when you grab the weight
value of two cubic meters of bronze the
results may surprise you this savage
Lionel crusher weighs in at a staggering
sixteen thousand kilograms or more than
35 thousand pounds that's over 17 tons
which is about the weight of two
Tyrannosaur
Rexes this is of course in estimation
since the weapons sizing used isn't 100%
accurate and it appears to be partially
made of some sort of stone which could
either raise or lower that number but
for the intents of this video this is
the number we're gonna go with now
finally we get to ask the question
exactly how strong is a Lionel to be
able to swing this weapon around and
hold it in just a single arm well we
could estimate this fairly quickly by
simply applying the weapons weight which
is thirty-five thousand pounds to both
arms since Lionel's can hold these
crushers with a single arm that means
that a Lionel can handle more than
70,000 pounds with both arms
that's like saying bro I curl 10 f-350
for trucks for reps so yeah Lionel's are
pretty dang strong but let's see how
well the King Koopa holds up Bowser has
been known to be immensely strong for as
long as he's been a character in Mario
games
fortunately finding out how strong
Bowser is will be a tad bit easier than
what we had to do with the Lionel's the
strongest thing we've ever seen Bowser
do in game would probably be from the
ending of Mario Galaxy 2 when spoiler
alert he literally survives being pulled
into a freakin black hole that's some
immense godlike strength but know that
we can't use that for this argument why
you ask well because he was actually
super Bowser when this happened to him
and it's really hard to measure what
that means for Bowser's normal strength
or even what happened here so we'll have
to go to a much more practical and
direct show of strength from our
favorite fire-breathing turtle in Mario
Odyssey towards the end of the game
another spoiler warning by the way Mario
actually takes control of Bowser in a
surprising change of direction and then
uses Bowser's powerful body to bust out
of the self-destructing honey loon Ridge
along the way you can run around jump
brief fire and slash through solid rock
yeah solid blocks a rock yes he does
have claws that help with this but it
still requires an immense amount of pure
strength to accomplish especially over
and over again so let's start estimating
first off how big are the blocks of
rocks
well Bowser has a height of
approximately 8 feet tall
judging from his appearance in Super
Smash Brothers ultimate and this video
comparing him to real-life president
Bowser you know the human one these
blocks are just barely taller than he is
in game aprox
one and a quarter times as tall so we'll
estimate their height at ten feet even
finding the cubic volume of a cube is
pretty easy you multiply the height
times the width times the depth which
for a cube will all be the same number
so 10 times 10 times 10 is 1,000 cubic
feet or 28.3 cubic meters now in order
to save some time we're gonna assume the
rocks from honeymoon Ridge are the same
as rocks from the moon which are very
similar to rocks from here on earth
meaning I'm going to assume they're just
made of common stone the formulae for
determining how much force required to
pierce through solid rock is really
rather confusing and it would take
forever to explain so in order to save
even more time I'm gonna jump to summing
it all up combining the volume of the
rock with the amount of force required
to break said rock then dividing that by
the precision points of his four claws
comes out to a whopping 7075 kilograms
or fifteen thousand five hundred ninety
seven pounds of weight required from one
of his arms to break through these solid
rock cubes now that's only about a
single t-rexes weight
meaning the lionel's per arm are roughly
twice as strong as Bowser so that's it
right Lionel's would clearly win in an
arm wrestle since they're stronger right
well not so fast there's one more thing
to consider because you see some of the
strongest men in the world can't beat
professional arm wrestlers because of a
tiny little detail called technique in
other words yes it takes strength to be
good at arm wrestling but it also
requires a good deal of proper arm
wrestling technique so let's take a look
at a classic picture of strength versus
technique recently there was an
unofficial arm wrestling match between
half Thorbjorn s'en also known as the
mountain from Game of Thrones
also known as the 2018 first place world
Strongest Man and Devon Laurette who has
been the world champion arm wrestler for
both arms three times over between the
two half Thor is obviously the larger
and stronger contestant but Devon was
able to pretty easily best the mountain
bringing this back to the logic between
Bowser and the Lionel between the two
Bowser is pretty obviously the more
intelligent contestant since he can
actually speak language and even command
armies and Lionel's literally get
confused by a very poorly made mask on a
very
man so yeah Bowser is more likely than
the Lionel to use proper technique but
will this be enough to counter a foe
that literally doubles his strength the
answer is yes yes it can
half Thor is more than twice as strong
as Devon since the armwrestling champion
can barely keep 80 kilograms in the air
yet the mountain can curl over 200
kilograms with both arms or over a
hundred kilograms with a single arm from
the ground all the way to over his head
for reps but since devon was able to
beat Thor I think it's safe to say that
while a Lionel may be able to benchpress
more than the King Koopa when Bowser
puts his mind to it he can take home the
world in our wrestle any day of the week
but that's just my own theory what do
you think let me know in a comment below
hey guys thank you so much for watching
I really hope you enjoyed this fun
strength theory pitting two fan favorite
villains against each other if you liked
this video and want to see more of my
content please be sure to LIKE and
subscribe with that belt to be notified
when I drop more videos as always huge
thank you to my amazing patrons and if
you're interested in a shadow at the end
of all my videos follow the link in the
description to find out how also down
there are links to my social media pages
and my current giveaway the prizes
include an amiibo of your choice a game
of your choice and even a Nintendo
switch console so you won't want to miss
out on this one it's really easy and
free to throw your name in the Hat all
it takes is a simple retweet and follow
so be sure to take a few moments to do
so you never know what may happen that's
all I've got for this video so I hope to
see you in the next one have a great
rest of your day this is Masson Tendo
bandit signing out
[Music]